do you think we'll ever see another
moment like GameStop in retail investing
I think what GameStop showed is that
retail investors are
a really really important part of the
markets and a constituency that can't be
ignored and a big part of that is due to
the impact of Robin Hood and the mission
Robin Hood was founded with the goal of
democratizing Finance it's easy to use
app made trading free and spurred a
generation of retail investors to jump
into stocks including GameStop GameStop
share is absolutely going nuts the
weapon of choice for these new Traders
are platforms like Robin Hood but since
then Robinhood has lost roughly half of
its active users now CEO Vlad tenev is
focused on growing Robinhood into
something more than just a trading app
wsj caught up with him at the company's
headquarters to hear how he hopes to
make Robin Hood the most trusted name in
finance what was the moment you knew
that you created something that changed
how everyday people invest end of 2019
when basically every single discount
brokerage in quick succession lowered
their commissions to zero and
essentially replicated our model and at
the time I remember
being a little bit nervous you know you
get all these questions what does this
mean for the company like we really have
to up our game to continue to
differentiate with our customers what
would you say is the next Frontier for
democratizing finance we've done a great
job with trading and self-directed
investing now the the next area we're
tackling is retirement and so we're the
first to offer a one percent match in an
individual retirement account and it's a
big part of our journey from helping
customers get started investing to
managing all of their finances and
providing service across all of their
financial needs a lot of the investors I
talk to do still associate Robin Hood
with GameStop and the trading
restrictions during that period so what
do you say to customers who lost trust
in Robinhood during that time
I
I understand
um
that perception but what I'd point to is
the amazing progress Robin Hood has made
and continues to make Robin Hood has
gone from an app that blasted confetti
after a user's First Trade to a company
offering retirement accounts and 4.9
interest on uninvested cash for premium
subscribers The disruptive brokerage is
looking more like a traditional Finance
firm and with its acquisition of credit
card startup X1 this year Robinhood has
a credit card in the works we think
credit's a huge opportunity there's so
many customers that are either
underserved or not adequately served
with their credit needs these days and I
think Robinhood can play a huge role
there in democratizing that space and
make it easier and a much better
experience to offer those products this
pivot to new offerings is part of the
company's strategy to attract and hold
on to users in this High rate
environment trading stocks isn't as
popular as it used to be in investors
now have other options for good returns
one of the really interesting things
about the investing business is it does
tend to be cyclical with growth coming
in waves in times where interest rates
are low like they were in in 2020 and in
2021 you see a lot of interest in
investing in the market and in other
times there's just less interest and so
what we look at there is how can we
improve our product and service and
continue to innovate for our Traders and
investors with things like 24-hour
market which makes us the first in the
U.S to offer round-the-clock trading for
single name stocks while getting into
retirement accounts looks more
traditional 24-hour market is anything
but it's a big shift in how users can
trade stocks like Amazon apple and Tesla
with 24-hour Trading
it just seemed ludicrous to me that you
know it's 2023 and investing in the most
liquid deepest markets in the world the
U.S capital markets is still tied to U.S
east Coast working hours everything is
is electronic elsewhere and services are
available when people need them and and
yet investing is kind of
this exception and when we looked into
it we realized that there's no reason
that it had to be this way we could work
with counterparties we could build the
technology to make that better and
24-hour market which launched a couple
of months ago is kind of the first step
in that direction so I think it's still
very early to tell what kind of impact
it'll have market-wide and I do believe
in not too long you'll see it become an
industry standard just like commission
free trading has become if that does
become industry standard are there any
risks you see involved one thing that
you have to remember is we already have
experience with assets that trade Around
the Clock if you look at the
cryptocurrency markets they trade 24 7
worldwide and you know we've we've been
offering customers access to to crypto
on the platform since 2018. speaking of
crypto it's obviously been a Hot Topic
in the regulatory space over the last
year
as one of the first brokerages to offer
crypto are you committed to offering
crypto to us customers moving forward
yeah and I think crypto is is here to
stay there's definitely been a lack of
regulatory Clarity and I think we're
going to continue to work with lawmakers
and and Regulators to push forward there
shares of Robin Hood have had a nice
run-up this year but they're still down
about 80 percent from their record high
from 2021. do you think there's anything
the market is under appreciating about
Robin Hood over a long time period
companies are valued on earnings growth
and the stock price tends to to track
that it might not happen for various
reasons in the short term what we can
continue to do is serve our customers
improve our products grow market share
but there's always more to do do you
still think Robin Hood is an underdog in
the financial services industry I do
Robinhood has been able to accomplish
quite a bit over the past 10 years since
we got the idea for it but still a very
young company and I do believe you know
10 years from now looking back to where
we are today we'll really appreciate
that we're still in the early stages of
Robin Hood and there's so much to do
even as Tana looks ahead a reminder of
Robin Hood's association with the
GameStop craze is out in theaters this
month that stock is
game starts have you seen the movie Dumb
money about the GameStop Saga in which
you are a character in the movie I have
not seen it having a movie created that
has Robin Hood featured is I think a
really important Testament to the impact
we've had but you have to remember the
movie's fiction and uh nobody sort of
talked to us about it so I think
I'm expecting it to be a fictionalized
account and hopefully some of it's true